sono tutti ragazzi benvenuti questi
uomini sono parigi oggi siamo tornati
finalmente su di 3 c dopo una vita siamo
in compagnia di pietro di step e di fare
un episodio incredibile su vena di tre
civili lasciato un bel live e ritorniamo
agli albori con questi bei ragazzoni che
non vedevo l'ora di rincon ciao quello
sei tu step come sempre
mettiamo solo un buco singolo nel
cappello perché solo occhio va bene
allora ragazzi o io o dei capelli in
questo personaggio censo o un
personaggio sotto i capelli ma siccome
oggi e jason lo fa surf che lo so che
non è mai magnanimo nei miei confronti
nel caso degli altri video per i ragazzi
cerchiamo di farci valere visto che di
solito non ci riesco quindi ragazzi
uniamoci vi prego non facciamo figure di
kakà per favore e o incastrato una mazza
da baseball nella credenza di interessa
ancora ci dobbiamo ragazzi dobbiamo
ricongiungerci ma dobbiamo parlare in
modo che stefan non capisca quello che
stiamo dicendo aspetto io sono vicino a
qualcuno anche i ok io sono sul
pavimento su un pavimento
c'è qualcosa in mano guarda che
linguaggio esca sicuramente stefy non ha
capito niente di quello che abbiamo
ma neanche io in realtà amici guardate
il la bloomberg in un casinò comunque di
veramente difficile non vedermi questi
capelli
secondo me o mi confondo
nell'adolescente se mi metto vicino un
cespuglio non capisci chi sono io che
cespugli va bene io sento marcelli fermo
stesso ma mio dio
stavo guardando il mare mi sono
avvicinato c'era c'era sempre che mi
fissano guarda che io sono molto
distante la loro quindi poi da loro ma
allora fare le cose per l'auto e dare
all'auto ma io sono di fronte all'altro
ma l'auto ma è qui che ci sono due di
auto comunque vorrei dire quella che è
ma come come no perché va dai vari
poteva avere dio mio come sia al butta
via avevano due batterie per il telefono
abbiamo il power bank ragazzi che così
prendo il mio cuore vieni qua
mentre vai a cambiare i vestiti alla tua
famiglia
vabbè che ci sono cascato addosso si fa
come si fa a fare quello che sto voglio
provare a fare dunque non passo in
avanti per non spingere che un gioco e
un po ma sei scemo ragazzi mi stai fermo
ha spinto the north aia non sono io e
non è non è quello che sembra dietro qua
dentro per favore perché davvero non
c'entro nulla
datemi una cura b per cortesia io mi
sono procurato che male mi sono fatto ma
si può spingere la gente cioè io non lo
sapevo fino a quando è chi riesce a
provarlo limite se non testato mi sono
spaccato un piede mi sto tenendo la
spalla il che è fantastico non c'è una
macchina elettrica che va solo alla
batteria per favore esatto sono quasi
morto a iavoloha del sale pietro vieni a
distrarre il nostro amico per favore
lasciatemi dentro ce l'hai ragazzi sono
troppo per la mamma sul problema
gigantino capire io non ho niente suo
amore c'è pietro c'è dietro pietro
dietro provo pietà
mi chiamo pensiamo picchiavano niente
sto morendo cosa faccio muoio cavolo
super finita pure io adesso le mani a
posto mi fate visto qualcosa
l'hack è male a yara come massimo che di
seguito di me potete dato il coltello
dalla distanza ma fatti mi sono sentito
fare malissimo ma non capito come perché
quando io che pure è neppure grazie
vieni che siamo noi però pensiamo
esattamente non vicini in questo esatto
sino ragazzi veramente che bisognerebbe
stare tutti uniti ce ne facciamo
veramente schifo se mi lasci stare
avendo le informazioni su dove loro ma
che poi io mi serve questo schifo di
persona 6 ma dall'altra parte della
mappa ma non dite che sono le moto ma
dite di delle altre sono per niente male
allo marchi lavoro e alla macchina lo
scopo non solo la macchina ma non c'è
niente nella macchina il problema era
inoltre che abbiamo riuscito io sono
inciampati una trappola di stef mai le
primarie noi son supplicando no profumo
re.te rallentato avvicinati un po alla
finestra
noi amiamo alla spalla tanto possa fare
tanto bello che non solo un
fisioterapista
non sono io no non lo conosce a lui si
genera mi dispiace è il mio lavoro
perdono clienti
non so se brava si potrebbe perdere il
vostro primo compagno di kayak e male
hai messo proprio male fatto ho
sbagliato niente volevo augurare
sopravivere non ce la può fare
non se la può fare a meno che non abbia
quel che ho detto non ci credo ma fermi
ma non è vero che ride e mica del mezza
cura tipo ma io posso vedere dove stesso
no non lo vedo proprio sos piante e le
meglio amici miei io posso darvi una
notizia incredibile non ho trovato
assolutamente mezza chiave magari a
tutti i cassetti
le cave invece ma che succede così che
male female incredibile pedone pedone
vedo le chiavi vedi che è vero è che
avesse un problema
sull'ultima problema chiuso e sono qua
dietro
maledizione vai vai vai per viper e sono
fatto male di nuovo che male non ho più
io non ho più niente neanche la dignità
la maledizione di mille chiavi prendi
prime chiave che chiavi edison per la
macchina capito sto morendo sto morendo
sfera se tutto è quella mafia che frutto
le chiavi avere della macchina perché
pronta l'auto ho capito che ci diceva
basta me ma le chiavi guardare la mappa
prendi le chiavi che prendi dimettere io
devo prendere che io devo farlo lo
faccio io lo faccio io ho capito è
difficile è lontano che devo fare tutto
io da fare con l'altro le chiavi mio dio
le ha provate lui ma è morto trovate i
luoghi del cuore grande complimento che
non mif attorno venuto miglior di questo
sogno e chiamare però non l'abbiamo
nostre mario in questo caso qualora
l'odio fecondo non so perché le foto
guarda te prende le chiavi che chiami
con le chiavi o ma digos e parlavate
dove diventa allora vecchietti me
terribile faremo mai
devi fare una cosa in questo momento ho
capito allora palla ho capito è
difficile oddio sta arrivando sta
arrivando però occhio per vai tu a
dietro occhio occhio allora io lo
distrae altezza criticato manca la
tanica manca la tanica perché mentre
metteva la tanica con l'om ha spinto nel
nella nella trappola quindi niente io
avevo una batteria e la batteria non
metta ho fatto il mio lavoro
pietro anch'io ho messo tanti cambi per
terra ma basta troppo elevata mandate
trappole esistono ma che qui è tornato
in vita nel mentre è uscito io sono
tornato e vino
forse dell'auto bene tornasse in vita
dove jason senti sto cercando sono la
macchina io sono partito ma non c'è
nessuno qua prendete come seguita non
sono capace e ho capito la sinistra si
ritrova sinistra ma che sinistra
all'indietro sono andati indietro
indietro siti che vi sto concentrando un
casino qua dove e jason mando avanti
che casino di vita come faccio a far
risalire sali successo niente però la
portiera dall'altra parte però c'è
quanto tempo un casino ora che un casino
ragazzi over era in un casinò guidare ve
lo dico noi non c'e niente ma infatti
non perché sono anche spaventato capito
quindi un casino proprio doppiamente
finita sinistra sinistra grazie torri
funziona se vissuti caparezza e tommy
jarvis incredibile grazie pietro nelle
chiavi prego sono quelle che i ragazzi
che sarà venerdì 13 con queste
bellissime persone
spero che i video vi sia piaciuto come
mi piace e noi come sempre ci rivediamo
al prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]